[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIA: The business day is coming to an end
at Davos and it's been
remarkable.
A few highlights:
"President Clinton, I'm campaigning against
female genital mutilation."
>>It's a great cause.
I'll follow up.
Bless you.
JULIA: My heart is going.
That was fantastic.
He's promised to follow up.
He said it's a fantastic cause.
And if I can get into the Clinton Initiative
that would be wonderful
and I think he will follow up, so that's great.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIA: I had ten minutes with Klaus Schwab,
who is the founder of the
World Economic Forum.
Again, he was very much behind me bringing
this cause here.
>> First, I think in order to -- to solve
those issues, you need to
really to engage all statehoods.
And it's, of course, and your community, it's
business, it's politics,
it's the young global leaders, so that's one
necessity to really make
progress.
JULIA: I met [INAUDIBLE] who is a personal
guru for me.
And just to see him in the flesh, have him
shake my hand so warmly,
it's amazing.
>>So I am so glad when I saw the result.
JULIA: A really inspirational meeting with
Jody Williams, who has won
the Noble Peace Price for her work on landmine
campaigns.
>>If you are consistent and transparent, which
I never say anything in
secret.
I say whatever the hell I want.
If people don't like it, tough.
Don't come listen to me, right?
But always transparent, always follow through
with what I said I was
going to do.
And even if they didn't like me, the opposition
in the military, they
respect me because they knew that I was a
a person of my word.
JULIA: Anthony Bell and the talked about global
health research just
how little data there is.
But also how little is known about the real
health impacts of FGM.
And lastly a couple of media interviews.
CNN, Associated Press TV.
I spoke with the BBC, the Sunday Times.
So a lot of coverage going on hopefully just
getting the word out and
spreading it widely.
[MUSIC PLAYING]